hi Joe hello they said you're a Formula
One racecar driver
now what happened dad what are we gonna
do now what happens now
hey did the doors yeah no but I mean
like that fold down like that
my mother likes to do all right Joe
let's go you see it's like a little
bumpy Wilson this is just because we're
smoothing out the the track so it wasn't
that kind of fast the way he took off
yeah a little faster you know now we're
gonna do it with autopilot off how fast
are we going now we're taking it easy
for you don't worry yeah I mean we've
gone past 80 miles an hour or we go we
can get a hundred no problem but we'll
take it easy for you likes it's a little
bumpy on the first ride so we really
can't go off the tracks see I worry
about our tunnel collapsing Elon these
tunnel reinforcing segments are four
times stronger than they need to be for
the load
what's with the color changes is that
just like is good red is red is slow oh
right right oh stop but there was a blue
yeah that was just for aesthetic brake
drama because a futuristic look now
what's happening what is this no no so
this is the elevator that car
Wow and normally the elevator would put
it on the side walls the elevator but we
thought we actually took four people to
see the actual system yes they kind of
like a steampunk vibe you can see how he
just popped out here yeah basically in
some of his you know in somebody's
backyard essentially yeah I know I know
beep oh yes let's pop out that was very
cool I said it was very scary for the
first couple seconds but it was also
very cool but if you're gonna do it you
might as well do it with Elon Musk by
your side if he's not scared I'm not
scared Joe were you scared
Joe was not scared either